[Musique]
menaces orange
cette scène aurait dû se jouer au sein
de la bibliothèque pour la 5e édition de
la nuit de la lecture saison
à défaut de pouvoir accueillir leur
jeune public les équipes ont eu la bonne
idée de mettre en scène des histoires
toute l'équipe était un peu frustrés
face au contexte et aux annulations
diverses
donc on s'est lancé dans un projet
dématérialisée chose qui est pas
évidente parce que on n'a pas forcément
ses compétences la en interne et on a
décidé de faire une version un peu
original de quai ce qu'on pourrait
trouver la nuit les bibliothécaires dans
les rayons qui mangent entre deux portes
des bibliothécaires qui se font acteurs
pour pallier la crise sanitaire
au bout il y à un film de 50 minutes
diffusés sur le fameux réseau social
on découvre au fur et à mesure des
espaces de la bibliothèque des lecteurs
enfin des bibliothécaires en train de
lire et dans notre celle du compte
on a deux militaires qui sont en train
de lire un livre et on a tout un public
de doudou à la place de notre public
habituel qui participent et qui fait en
sorte de faire vivre l'histoire un bouc
faith dans cette bibliothèque c'est un
concours original qui est proposé aux
lecteurs
posté sa meilleure photo avec une
couverture de livre pour trouver les
bons livres il faut un petit peu
il faut fureter dans les rayons parmi
les rayonnages de la médiathèque
et puis essayer de trouver le livre qui
va nous attirer nous corresponde voilà
ont trouvé une belle belle couverture on
a lancé en parallèle aussi un concours
de doudou de photos de doudou on a déjà
quelques photos qui sont arrivés doudou
et on attend avec impatience les
prochains photos de bouc fays 7/5 ni de
la lecture sera virtuel ou ne sera pas